SPEAKER 1: Today
at Google, we are
delighted to welcome Latha
Palaniappan and Deepa Prahalad.
Dr. Palaniappan is a Professor
of Medicine at Stanford,
where for the last 20 years,
she has studied and worked
on cardiovascular disease
and diabetes in South Asians.
Ms. Prahalad comes from
a management consulting
background specializing
in emerging markets,
and is now on the
board of Arogya World,
where she focuses on
growth and design.
And she wrote a book titled
"Predictable Magic," which
attempts to unite strategy
and design thinking.
They are here today
to discuss their work
at Arogya World, a global health
nonprofit organization working
to prevent non-communicable
diseases, e.g. diabetes, heart
disease, cancer, and
chronic lung diseases
through health education
and lifestyle change.
Please join me in welcoming
to Google Latha Palaniappan
and Deepa Prahalad.
[APPLAUSE]
LATHA PALANIAPPAN: Thank
you for coming out today.
I'm going to tell you a
little bit about myself.
My name's Latha Palaniappan.
I'm currently a Professor
of Medicine at Stanford.
I spend most of my
time doing research
in heart disease and diabetes.
I do work on electronic health
records, mortality records.
And I do clinical trials
in Type 2 diabetes,
trying to promote
physical activity
in people with Type 2 diabetes.
And I teach first-year medical
student population health.
So that's how to take care
of large groups of people.
And I also see patients in
Stanford's Executive Medicine
program.
And we're trying to start a
genetic and pharmacogenetic
testing program there to bring
evidence-based genetic testing.
So I want to, before
we start today,
have us think a little
bit about diabetes.
And I'm going to be presenting
some statistics on diabetes
around the world.
But if you could think for a
moment why you think diabetes
is increasing so
much in prevalence.
Now, you probably have
heard in the papers
that diabetes is increasing.
And I wonder if
anyone in the audience
has any thoughts on that.
Maybe what brought
you here today?
If you have a family
member with diabetes.
AUDIENCE: Standard
American diet.
LATHA PALANIAPPAN:
Standard American diet.
Any more color to that?
What is the standard
American diet?
AUDIENCE: Too much
sugar and fat.
LATHA PALANIAPPAN: Too
much sugar and fat.
And in fact, one of my
colleagues at Stanford
recently wrote a paper that
was published in "JAMA" showing
that both low-fat and
low-carb diets, when healthy,
promoted weight loss.
So that kind of put an end to
the low-carb/low-fat debate,
I hope.
I think we will
continue to debate
about that because people
feel that certain diets work
for them more than another.
But it did show in the end
that a calorie is a calorie.
And having the
appropriate amount
of calories for
your body size is
helpful for maintaining
a healthy weight
and preventing chronic
diseases in general.
OK.
So let's talk about the
global epidemic of diabetes.
And particularly,
what we're trying
to do in preventing
this epidemic.
So this is a graph of
diabetes cases in the US.
So you can see, the US--
around the world and in the US.
So you can see in
the US in green,
there are 37 million
cases of diabetes.
And the black part
on the side shows you
what percentage is undiagnosed.
So you can see in different
areas of the world,
there are different proportions
of undiagnosed diabetes.
And I hope that
you in the audience
have gotten tested for diabetes.
But can anyone tell me
how we test for diabetes?
AUDIENCE: Something to do
with insulin and blood sugar.
LATHA PALANIAPPAN:
Insulin and blood sugar.
Great answer.
So that's the absolute
correct answer.
So we try to check
your blood sugar.
So we check either
a fasting number
in the morning of
your blood sugar,
or what we call a glycosolated
hemoglobin, hemoglobin A1c.
Because as we have more
glucose in our bodies,
it attaches onto our hemoglobin.
And we can measure those levels.
And then, another
way that we can do it
is through an oral
glucose tolerance test.
And that's sort of
drinking a glucose load,
and then checking your
glucose after two hours
to see how your body
processes glucose.
So all of these things,
you can imagine,
are a little hard to do because
they involve blood tests
in resource-limited settings.
So I hope in partnership
with technology companies
like Google, that we'll
be able to improve
the diagnosis of
diabetes, and be
able to do it without expensive
blood tests going forward.
So you can see in the
world, 382 million people
are living with diabetes.
And about half of
those are diagnosed
and half are undiagnosed.
OK.
So the top 10 countries by
number of diabetes cases.
So the top countries
are China and India.
The prevalence of diabetes
is about the same.
So about 10%.
It ranges in these
countries from 7% to 14%,
depending on if
you're urban or rural,
and what your familial
risk factors are.
And the reason that
the number of cases
are so high in
China and India is
because the absolute number
of people are so high right.
In China, India, they're our
largest countries in the world.
And so you can see
the US is third there.
A distant third.
And the number of cases
of diabetes in the US
are increasing as well.
And the greatest
projected increase
is in the Western Pacific.
So China, Korea, Japan Vietnam,
Indonesia, and Australia.
The number of
cases are projected
to increase by about 50%.
And this is just a graph
showing the economic background
of these countries.
So high income is yellow,
upper middle is orange,
lower middle is pink,
and low income is red.
And so you can see there
again, that the proportion
of undiagnosed changes depending
on the economic background
and situation of
those countries.
With a really high proportion
undiagnosed, again,
in India and China.
And the high-income countries
having a little bit less
undiagnosed, but still a
significant proportion.
Even in the US, we have
a significant proportion
of undiagnosed diabetes,
simply because people aren't
going in and getting tested.
And it does take some
effort to go ahead and get
tested for Type 2 diabetes.
And Asia represents about 60%
of the diabetic populations
worldwide.
OK.
So we are focusing today
particularly on South Asia.
And this is--
Dr. Prahalad, who
will speak after me,
is the purpose of the
nonprofit reducing diabetes
in South Asia, which has a
particularly high prevalence
of diabetes.
So this is a map of South Asia.
We commonly think of India
representing South Asia.
And it is a major part
of the subcontinent.
And 90% of the South Asians
in California are from India.
But also, South Asians are
from Pakistan, Nepal, Bhutan,
and Bangladesh, and
Sri Lanka as well.
And this is a map
of the Bay Area
of the Census in this area,
and what percent of people
are Asian Indian by county.
So you can see
there, particularly
around Alameda in the
Fremont area particularly,
it's about 10% Asian Indians.
So 1 out of 10 people
are South Asian.
And in Santa Clara, where we are
now, about 1 out of 15 people
are Asian Indian.
So this is a study I
did earlier in my career
looking at mortality
records of California,
and looking at
coronary heart disease.
Because diabetes is a risk
factor for heart disease
and diabetes prevalence is so
much higher in South Asians,
particularly among
young Indian men.
So 25 to 44.
Their risk of heart disease is
almost three times as high-- so
that tall red bar.
Compared to the
total population,
which is in green, the
non-Hispanic white population
in orange, the Hispanic
population in blue,
the African American or
black population in brown,
and the Chinese
population in blue,
and Japanese population
in yellow there.
And the Indian
population is in red.
And what got me into
the business that I'm in
is that my father died
of a heart attack at 39.
I grew up in Michigan and
lived there at the time,
but he represented that
three times higher risk
in the young men 25 to 44.
So I encourage you, if you
know of anyone in this race
ethnic group, they're at
particularly high risk
for heart disease
and should be tested
for diabetes and other risk
factors for heart disease.
So this is another study that
I did using data from Palo Alto
Medical Foundation.
So we collected race
ethnic information
at Palo Alto Medical
Foundation, because it is so
highly prevalently Asian.
So the Bay Area is
about 30% Asian,
and it has good
representation of all
of these Asian subgroups.
Anyone here get their care from
Paul Alto Medical Foundation?
It's a great place.
It's a good place to get care.
So you can see that all Asians
in general have higher odds.
So this is the likelihood
of having diabetes
among that group compared to
non-Hispanic whites, about
double the risk.
So men are on the
left, women are
on the right in all the arrows.
And the statistically
significant numbers
are in bold there.
So you can see that among
the Asian subgroups when
you aggregate them, there is
a higher risk of diabetes.
And when you disaggregate
the Asian subgroups,
some groups have much higher
risk than other groups.
Namely, Asian Indians and
Filipinos in this case
have three to four
times the risk.
And other Asian groups
also have higher risk,
like Chinese,
Japanese, and Korean.
And these are all
age-adjusted as well
given the slightly younger
age substructure of Asians
in the US.
OK.
So why do Asians and perhaps
Asian Indians in particular
have more risk of diabetes?
So this is a paper
that was published
in "Lancet" by two of the people
that I consider my mentors,
[INAUDIBLE].
And they're at an
Indian wedding,
so you can see the
saris in the background.
And [INAUDIBLE] is the
non-Hispanic white researcher
on your left and [INAUDIBLE]
is the Indian researcher
on your right.
And you can see that they have
an identical BMI, Body Mass
Index, of 22.3, but
their body fat--
and sorry, it's covered
there by the notation--
the slide advancer.
But it's three times as high
for the Indian researcher.
It's about 9% versus 27%.
So at an identical level of body
mass index, there's more fat.
And so next to them,
they have DEXA scans.
So these are scans that
we normally do for bone.
But you can also see fat
and muscle in those scans.
And in a DEXA scan,
muscle is more white.
So you can see the
non-Hispanic white researcher
has more muscle.
You can see it particularly
around the thighs,
in the abdominal area.
Whereas, the Indian
researcher does,
it is more sort of
dark on that DEXA scan.
So that's indicative
of more fat.
So Asians-- based on data
like this and other work
that I'll show you, the WHO
recommended a lower body
mass index cut point for Asians.
So it's 23 and lower.
And for non-Hispanic
whites, it's 25 and lower.
So this is a study
that I did showing
that at similar levels
of body mass index,
there is higher
risk of something
called metabolic syndrome,
which is pre-diabetes.
It's a combination of
triglycerides, low HDL, which
is the good cholesterol; high
glucose, obesity, as well as
blood pressure greater
than 130 over 85.
So you can see on the x-axis,
on the horizontal axis,
is the body mass indices.
And on the y-axis
is the probability
of having metabolic syndrome.
And Asian Indians
are on the red curve
and non-Hispanic whites
are on the blue curve.
And you can see that at every
level of body mass index,
that Asian Indians
have higher probability
of having this pre-diabetes.
And it is very difficult
to have a BMI of 23.
At this moment, I stand in
front of you with a BMI of 23.
But sometimes, on Mondays after
a weekend of lots of parties,
I gain 3 pounds.
And I'm a very short
person, and my BMI is 24.
So it's very hard to
maintain that BMI of 23.
But I have to do it because I
have to practice what I preach.
So you can see here-- and this
is also from Palo Alto Medical
Foundation-- the
range of body mass
index for non-Hispanic whites
on the left and Asian Indians
on the right, for women on
the left and men on the right.
And you can see that a BMI of
25 and higher-- so 50% of women
in the Palo Alto Medical
Foundation Electronic Health
Record Database.
So there's about a million
people in that database.
50% of non-Hispanic women
were at at-risk BMI.
And about 60% of
Asian Indian women
had a BMI of 23 and higher.
So we have a long way
to go to get people
at the appropriate
level of weight.
And for men, it was 8
out of 10 non-Hispanic
white men were not at the
appropriate or optimal weight.
And 9 out of 10
Asian Indian men.
So when I was at Palo
Alto Medical Foundation,
I had a specific clinic
for South Asians.
And 9 out of 10 of the people
that I saw, we had to do work
to get them down to a
lower level of body weight.
So when you go to
see your doctor,
your doctor might use your
clinical data, including
your gender and your HDL,
your good cholesterol,
and your total cholesterol.
And whether your blood
pressure is high or low
or whether or not
you smoke to estimate
your risk of atherosclerotic
cardiovascular disease.
This is called an
ASCVD risk calculator.
So one thing that I
want us to be aware of
is that these risk
calculators are mainly
based on non-Hispanic
white European populations.
And they might underestimate
the risk in some groups,
such as South Asians.
I also do work in disaggregating
Hispanic subgroups.
So Puerto Ricans and Cubans
can also be underestimated.
So you should be aware that our
current risk calculators may
not be accurate in all groups.
And we should be
aware of what data
was used to create
those risk predictions.
And I hope that with aggregating
larger and larger data sets,
that we'll be able to
improve our risk prediction.
OK.
So what can we do?
And Dr. Prahalad, who
will speak after me,
will speak a little bit
more about the nonprofit
and what they are
doing specifically.
But you know, we heard that it's
sort of the Western lifestyle.
And you sort of hit it right on
the head with red meat, sugar,
sitting at a computer, smoking,
refined grains, traffic,
alcohol, sort of
all of these things
that are contributing to
the diabetes epidemic.
But one thing that I want to
sort of point out in a point
that I make is that
in rural areas that
have agrarian lifestyles,
diabetes rates are actually
quite low.
Subsistence farming
isn't a great way
to live for a lot of reasons,
but diabetes is not very high.
So people tend to have a lot
of physical activity, not
a lot of calories, not a lot of
trans fats or saturated fats.
And diabetes rates are low.
But then, when they go to
more of an urban lifestyle
with eating Big Macs and
fries, so high-fat diets as you
mentioned, these
rates of diabetes
and cardiovascular
disease can go up.
But then, we get to
live, maybe in an area
like we do in the
Bay Area, where
we have access to
exercise, like SoulCycle,
and Orangetheory, and Pilates.
And also, access to great
food, like Sprouts and--
I don't know. l think there
must be 10 different salad
places here.
And so when we improve
our socioeconomic status
in this country, we can
also lower diabetes rates.
So in the US, people with
higher socioeconomic status
have lower diabetes rates.
And this is changing in
developing countries.
But in general, people with
lower socioeconomic status
in developing countries had
lower rates of diabetes.
And this is called the
epidemiologic transition,
when you go to higher
socioeconomic status
in developing countries
and have higher
rates of chronic disease.
But we're seeing that flip
a little bit now as well.
But how can we avoid this
lifestyle transition?
How can we in
developing countries
go from this Agrarian
lifestyle to one in which we
can translate to more--
higher SES in higher-income
countries' lifestyles?
So I think there's
many ways to do this.
And Dr. Prahalad will talk a
little bit more about these.
And this is from a paper I
wrote for the American Heart
Association looking at the--
it was called "The Community
Guide," about how communities
can improve rates of diabetes.
So there's many axes on legal,
community, as well as risk
factors and early diagnoses.
So one of the things that we did
for diet was banned trans fats.
So many countries have
banned trans fats.
And that has helped.
It has bent the curve in terms
of lowering diabetes rates.
Also, the sedentary lifestyle.
And I think Google has
been wonderful in providing
all the wonderful bikes
outside and other healthy--
encouraging healthy habits.
I saw lots of fruit
available outside.
And trying to decrease
even sitting at a computer.
So getting up and taking breaks.
I ask my patients
to do that a lot.
It will go a long way
towards preventing diabetes
and other chronic disease.
Tobacco.
So we don't have
tobacco advertising
on our TV stations for
our kids to see in the US.
But this is something
that could be implemented
in developing countries.
And unfortunately,
developing countries
are the place that
the tobacco companies
are going to advertise
more and get more smokers.
So that's something
that hopefully, we
can prevent going forward.
And treatment of high
blood pressure and lipids.
So guidelines on how
to screen for this.
I talked a little
bit about that.
As well as early recognition
of symptomatic disease,
perhaps with screening
with coronary artery
calcium and other newer
biomarkers that are coming out.
So I think we've come
a long way in the US.
I think that we
have learned lessons
here that would be great to
transmit to other developing
countries.
And I'm looking forward
to hearing more about
how we can do that.
[APPLAUSE]
DEEPA PRAHALAD: Thank you.
It's an honor to be here.
And I am just going
to load my present--
how do I get the [INAUDIBLE]?
OK, there we go.
Thank you, everybody,
for coming.
And I would like to just
spend a little bit of time--
I think Dr. Latha Palaniappan
has done a fantastic
job of talking about some
of the unique challenges
from a medical standpoint.
And as a nonprofit, we really
have this additional challenge
of saying, we have
this information,
but how do we make
it actionable?
And how do we create awareness?
Because I think we all
know in emerging markets,
the awareness is an issue.
The education levels.
And a lot of people who
are in rural areas--
culturally, there are
even terms that said,
diabetes is a rich
person's disease.
So the awareness that
this could happen at all
is not there in many cases.
And we also really said when we
looked around at our community
here, there really isn't
a single family that
hasn't been touched by one of
these diseases in some manner.
And so that's how
I got involved.
I don't have a
clinical background.
But we really are trying to
use design and innovation
to help drive awareness and
some kind of actionable steps
in this process.
So what we really did is
we have a nonprofit called
Arogya World.
Arogya is a Sanskrit
word that means health,
to live a life without disease.
And we really
said, let's see how
we can do some kind
of actionable course
to change the course
of chronic disease.
And we really settled on
three fundamental pillars
of awareness, action,
really providing people
tools, not just information.
And creating alliances
with people who
had information that we could
bring to a new audience.
Currently, we've reached
about 3.7 million people.
And we have plans to double
our outreach by 2020.
And I'm not going to
spend a lot of time
on this, because I think it
was especially well-covered.
66% of the deaths
in the world are
from non-communicable diseases.
And these are 80% of the
deaths in developing countries.
And the economic impact of
that is absolutely devastating.
And this is really
kind of the challenge
in emerging markets is you
have a lot of what I would call
this good/bad news,
where a lot of this
is because of increased life
expectancy from dealing fairly
well with infectious disease.
So now, people are
living long enough.
But because of the
demographics, you
have this challenge where you're
dealing with malnutrition,
and diabetes, and heart
disease at the same time, which
makes it extremely difficult
to get information across.
And we know ultimately
that three behavior changes
can really change the
course of chronic disease--
healthy eating, exercise,
and avoiding diabetes.
And the gains from that
are quite significant.
We can actually prevent 80%
of diabetes and heart disease
and 40% of cancers.
That is provided the information
is available and acted upon.
And so that's what we
have tried to address.
And I think where we
realized how important this
is, is because despite all the
economic growth that people are
excited about, this can actually
cripple any economic gains made
in many emerging countries.
We have 50% of the population
that dies from chronic disease.
20% of the population
has at least one
of these-- heart
disease, diabetes,
or some type of cancer.
And Indians also get these
diseases much earlier
in their prime working life.
So you can see the
statistics of $4.8 trillion
in lost economic output
by 2030 is significant.
And if people don't
have that themselves,
they tend to be very concerned
because they tend to be
caregivers for their parents.
Young professionals
of both genders
tend to take on
that responsibility.
So it's an issue even
for people who are not
suffering from one of these.
And what we realized
when we did,
I think the first
10,000 women survey,
is that this economic impact is
particularly severe for women.
Women have been the focus of
a lot of development efforts.
And what we did was take 10
countries around the world.
And we surveyed 1,000
women and said, what
is the impact in your lives?
And what we're finding
is that 50% of people--
women are saying,
yes, we are having
to be the primary caregiver for
even one person with an NCD.
That can cut family
income by half.
And it also means that
about 25% of people
who were in our
survey were saying
that they have been
forced to leave
the workforce for
extended periods.
So we decided to say, all right.
How do we empower women?
And that was a fine line,
because I think many efforts
today in wellness--
while their focus
is women, they tend
to overwhelm and place
a lot of extra burden
solely on one person who may
be overburdened in any case.
And we said, we need
to design something
that's flexible, lean,
and can be adapted.
Because India is a very
rapidly-changing environment.
The types of phones that people
have where they could receive
messages, where they can
understand what their risk
factors are changing.
And many of the rural
areas, what has happened
is that they are
very exciting targets
for multinational companies.
What can be offered
cheaply however,
is not the Sprout stuff.
It's the junk food that stays--
has a very long shelf life and
it doesn't wear out easily.
And what's happening is that
those are the first things that
are offered, because
kind of an entry
point to a new
group of consumers--
and there isn't a
lot of awareness.
People tend to like
those because they're
in small sample sizes
and because they're
seen as very hygienic.
So it's a huge problem.
And this is the first
generation in many cases
in some of those
areas that can afford
to give these kids treats
that they never had.
So we knew we had to really
have a low-cost, scalable,
and user-friendly
way to do this.
And what we settled on is what I
call our doorstep health model,
where we basically say the best
way to help women and families
is to make sure that they
are not the sole person.
They are trying to take charge
of their family's health.
We know that
they're the drivers.
But we have a
school program where
children in seventh
and eighth grade
get a set of really interesting
game-based exercises
where they have the awareness
created at an early stage.
We have a workplace initiative.
Many employers are really
interested in making sure
that their employees get
this information early on.
And for many people who are
out in very disparate areas,
we have mHealth
messages that come over.
And they are very simple,
action-based messages.
We don't give anybody
statistics about diabetes.
We tell them concrete
things they can do--
reduce your intake
of these grains.
So we've created a
very friendly voice
that is geared toward inspiring
people to take action.
And quickly, we have actually
a list of our genesis
we've created.
Our newest thing
is an initiative
called MyThali, which is
basically similar to the US
government's
MyPlate, where we've
taken nutritional
guidelines and tried
to create an icon-based system
so people actually understand
visually what these
guidelines mean.
And what we have found
in terms of our focus
is really saying that we
want to use technology
to spread awareness,
but we're not
going to become a
technology company.
That's not our focus.
We're not trying to create tons
of cool add-ons to our text
messages or even our
app in the workplace.
What we're really trying
to do in the workplace--
we will have an app that allows
people to measure and record.
But for that text message
program, what we've really done
is give people very
simple messages.
And we've tried
to motivate them.
We didn't want to have
the voice of a clinician.
We all love and
respect our doctors.
And we get the most expensive
ones that we can afford,
but we don't want to
talk to them every day.
Nor do we want to be gentle--
have gentle reminders
from friends and family
about what we should eat,
when we're over-eating.
And so having that encouragement
was really important.
What we also realized after
we had text messages going out
for many months in
different languages
is, of course like anything
else, it becomes easier to tune
out.
So we partnered with a
company called [INAUDIBLE]
that does periodic voice
messages as well, where
you actually get a phone call.
A message of encouragement.
You get a story from
somebody else to say, oh,
this is what I tried.
Here's a recipe.
Here was my success story.
And so we really designed
to inspire action.
And we have this
self-reinforcing model
of workplace, school,
and text messages.
So that we make sure that we
have the same thing coming in
from various places.
And what we were very
encouraged to find
in our very first survey when we
reached a million customers is
that for an mHealth
initiative, we actually
were able to
achieve a 15% impact
based on our surveys,
which is highly unusual.
Nokia was our initial partner
in sending out these messages.
And people reported--
15% of people
reported 4 behavior changes.
In the workplace context over
time, what we would like to do
is really do some kind of
clinical measurement for people
who opt-in.
And we had a very good response
from the younger generation,
which was the most encouraging.
We had a lot of students
reporting that they
had no idea about diabetes.
They had kind of heard a
little bit about junk food,
but a lot of teachers said that
these simple activities really
brought the message home.
So in seventh
grade, what we do is
we have children take
part in activities.
But in eighth grade--
they do a two-your
curriculum with us.
In eighth grade, they bring
their parents and families in
to also receive this information
and get concrete tips.
And people said that
was incredibly helpful.
We've partnered with some of
the leading NGOs in India,
like [INAUDIBLE].
And we basically give
them training materials
and expand our reach that way.
One of the really exciting
things we're doing
is this initiative
called MyThali,
which we are doing for both
North and South Indian food.
The nutrition
guidelines in India
are very complicated, even
for highly-educated people
to understand.
When they say, we need 250
grams of rice or we need this,
what does that actually mean?
So we've created an
icon-based pictorial model.
We are also working to over
time, physically create a plate
and serving spoons
of appropriate sizes,
so people are able to
quickly and easily comply.
So a lot of our focus is exactly
on that, is really creating
a lot of ease of compliance.
And then, our school
program we also were
able to achieve a 14% impact.
And what we really
had was simple things
relating this battle
to snakes and ladders.
You know, this is just such a
fundamentally different issue
for India, because the entire
health system has been really
geared toward
infectious disease,
where you do need to have
these limited interventions,
where you have to
convince someone
to take a vaccine or something.
But lifestyle diseases
are different.
And the system is
not set up for that.
So we found that these
very easy, visual ways
of communicating
and giving people
the idea of what the impact of
obesity can be, wear a backpack
and try to do a race with all
these extra pounds on you.
Those are the kind of
things that make it real
and tend to have a really
experiential component that
stays.
And we have also signed up a
lot of leading Indian corporates
and organizations, like
the Indian Railways,
which is the largest
employer in the world.
And with 1.3 million
employees, Reliance, Wipro,
many of these
companies, to say, here.
Here is a simple,
downloadable app.
Get the text messages.
And now, we have
worked with them
and we have partnered with
activity tracking companies
and created an
app so that we can
be a one-stop shop
not only for diabetes,
but for overall wellness.
And we are testing and
measuring the impact of that
going forward.
And we are covering about 2.3
million employees currently.
And we're expecting
that to increase.
And what we knew also was that
anything that we designed,
we know that both the
tools, the information,
the guidelines around
all of these diseases
are evolving very rapidly.
So we didn't want to be
too rigid in our design.
We just saw this exciting
news about Google
having an AI eye scan that
can detect your cardiac risk.
We know that we've been able to
limit the pinpricks with some
of the diabetes
measuring devices.
Even our understanding
of what healthy eating is
continues to evolve.
So we realize that kind
of positioning ourselves
as experts wasn't the way to
gain long-term credibility.
What we wanted to
be was somebody
who was a friend and
partner along the journey
and able to create
a conversation
to have information exchange.
We also want to always be able
to learn from the people we're
trying to serve.
So for example, in our schools
program, what we learned
is we gave people information
about a healthy breakfast.
And we realized, there's
a component of 10% to 15%
of people who maybe don't
get a breakfast before they
come to school.
And their primary
meal during the day
is actually at their school.
So we said, how do we
then revise, and rethink,
and help families understand
what they can still do?
And we realized that
this two-way information
flow was going to be critical
for us going forward.
And that's how we have
structured all of our programs,
with continuously
getting feedback as well
as giving suggestions.
We are very excited.
We've been able to reach
this kind of impact
only because we've had
amazingly committed partners who
have helped us really expand
in schools, workplaces.
This is a very small
number of them.
And what we got as we learned
a lot is people saying,
we need this
information in the US.
What you've learned
and the cost at which
you're able to
deliver impact really
could make a
difference in the US,
in Europe, in other
emerging markets.
And we agree
So what we are trying
to do is actually
take what we've learned
and expand our reach here.
We're experimenting with
an Indo American Center
here in Chicago, and trying
to see how we can best
adjust some of our
programs to audiences
in different parts of
the world because there's
different access and
a different awareness.
We started a California
working group last year.
And as far as going
forward, how would
we like to expand our reach
is really getting feedback,
having people get involved.
Never ones to turn
down a donation,
we're at arogyaworld.org.
But what we really want to do
is have people share information
with us on how they were able
to create those lifestyle
changes for themselves,
for their family.
Because we really believe
now we have a channel
to distribute that
information far and wide,
and help us really spread
the word and have an impact.
And I think the cost at which
we were able to reach people
is pretty amazing.
Given other alternatives,
we're able to create outreach
for $0.50.
We can actually create impact
and behavior change based
on our surveys for about $6.50,
which is highly unusual in this
type of an effort.
So we're really proud of
what we've done so far,
and happy to take any questions
and get your feedback as well.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: I have a question.
DEEPA PRAHALAD: OK.
SPEAKER 1: So you showed the
picture of the Google scan.
I think it was of an eye.
And I guess that's one
example of something
Google is doing on this front.
Is there anything else that you
admire that Google is doing,
or that you would like to
perhaps partner with Google on,
or some technologies that Google
is working on that you think
might be able to help
Arogya on its mission?
DEEPA PRAHALAD: Well,
I think one thing--
do you want to come up here?
One thing that we have seen some
interest from in our workplace
offerings is really saying--
you know, young employees
in India, for example.
Even if they are not
personally affected,
the burden of caring
for parents is
something that really looms
large for a lot of people
at a very young age.
And kind of the social
contract culturally
is that children really
take care of their parents
in their old age.
And because they get the
disease so much younger,
really helping young
employees understand
how to care for their
parents is one thing.
We have seen, even
in the US now,
because so many people
wear activity trackers,
they're able to integrate
some of that information
into city planning.
India is at a stage where now
you're saying, OK, there--
to prevent this migration from
rural areas to urban areas,
and all the consequences
that entails,
people are able to use
that data from activity
trackers to do smarter planning.
There are probably 400
to 500 cities in India
that are saying, we need
to create infrastructure
so people stay where they are.
So understanding,
how does that work?
What does that mean?
That's one of those
really interesting things.
And I know the tech
companies and the pharma
have been really
involved in trying
to create new diagnostics
and new ways to monitor.
So anything that lets
people do that at a lower
cost will make this
disproportionate impact,
I think, in
countries like India.
LATHA PALANIAPPAN: So I agree.
And to build on
that, for my patients
I would love some type of
noninvasive glucose monitoring,
because I think
it is really hard.
Currently, you have
to prick your finger,
and put it on a
little piece of paper,
and stick it in the machine,
and see what the number is.
So some way-- and I've worked
with some companies that
are using light technology to
perhaps look at the wavelengths
on hemoglobin to see what the
glycosylation of the hemoglobin
is to detect the glucose levels.
So noninvasive glucose
monitoring as well as
continuous glucose monitoring.
So my patients are
so surprised by when
they eat, if they
prick their finger,
their glucose is higher.
And sort of really
connecting what
you're putting in
your body and what's
happening to your glucose.
And what is happening long term
to your heart disease risk is,
I think--
would be great to connect
the dots for our patients.
AUDIENCE: I think
the health data
that you showed
at the beginning,
it's mostly very broad.
And I guess, it's
quite epidemiological.
Sorry about that.
LATHA PALANIAPPAN:
Yes, epidemiological.
AUDIENCE: But I feel
like there's actually
more detail available.
For instance, with
a plant-based diet.
So if you look at the
Adventist studies and so on.
So I feel like it could be
a little bit more aggressive
maybe, about promoting
very particular things.
Say, you've cut out the cheese.
Maybe that's not so
big a problem in India.
But like, I'm from Germany.
So I was eating a lot of cheese.
So basically, cut
off the cheese.
How about the other thing?
Basically, you go from avoiding
meat and you avoid fish.
But you also look at
all the opportunities
that it actually increases
your quality of life
because it's not just
about losing the weight.
I think basically, the
thing is a little bit--
the gist of I think what you
have in your health information
is mostly lowering
your weight, so you
reduce your risk of diabetes.
But there's a whole host
of other side effects
which are positive basically,
by particular diet changes.
And also, of course,
exercise that comes with it.
LATHA PALANIAPPAN: Absolutely.
I completely agree with you.
And to restate a
little bit is sort
of like there were some broad
strokes about diabetes rates
and sort of an ecological
sort of argument
that increased diabetes
is caused by increased
obesity in general.
When I talk to patients,
I talk about sort
of kind of rough
tuning and fine tuning.
So one third of the
people in this country
are at normal weight.
One third.
One third are overweight
and one third is obese.
So in that one third
that is normal weight,
I agree that fine
tuning is very needed.
So looking exactly at
a 24-hour food recall.
So that's what we do
with our patients,
like seeing what they
ate in the last 24 hours.
And seeing where there
can be more protein
and a substitution for more of
a whole grain than a refined
grain.
And some of these interventions
that are culturally specific,
like the My Thali.
I did a study where
we interviewed
South Asian patients.
And they would go
see a nutritionist.
And the patient said,
oh, they told me not
to eat burgers and
fries and cheese.
And they never ate those
things anyway, right?
So nobody ever told them
about chapati and dal.
And you know, that dal
is mostly a carbohydrate.
And if you want
protein, you might
have to look at other sources.
I do studies on physical
activity, actually.
In those normal
weight diabetics,
like, is it better for them
to do strength training
or aerobic training?
So we have a study where
we're randomizing people
to strength training only,
aerobic training only,
or a combination of both.
So I agree, there's
plenty of room
for fine tuning both diet
and exercise that should
be done on an individual level.
So I agree with you.
DEEPA PRAHALAD: And I think
from the nonprofit side,
we were just
concerned that a lot
of the basic-level awareness
just isn't there at all.
Because historically,
it has been a luxury
to eat sweets and everything.
So even if you look
at the terminology
in some Indian languages,
diabetes is the king's disease.
AUDIENCE: Positive
message also, right?
Here, it's blueberries.
Maybe it's mangoes or
something else in India
that people really like.
DEEPA PRAHALAD: No, that is
what most of our text messages--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: They're
very sweet, right?
But they taste good.
They taste good and
they're healthy.
DEEPA PRAHALAD: That's the
text message program, is we
really tell people what
they should do instead.
We don't give them any
statistical data at all.
What we do is these
changes would help you,
would help your family.
But that's the rub is that a lot
of these things that are quite
healthy have become expensive.
And that's what we're
always trying to balance.
And that's true as well here
among lower-income groups.
So that's always the challenge.
You know, you can give
people information
that's not actionable.
So we're always
trying to refine.
And so we have very different
messages in the workplace
program for example,
versus what goes out
to a more general population.
LATHA PALANIAPPAN:
Sort of, how can you
continue to eat like a
pauper when you can afford
to eat like a king, right?
That's difficult. Thank you.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Well, thank you,
Dr. Palaniappan.
Dr. Prahalad.
Thank you, everyone, for coming.
LATHA PALANIAPPAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]